hi in this video I'll be talking about
expression Victor so far we are talking
about cloning strategies several vectors
using cloning plasmid and also the viral
plasmids etc and in this specific video
we'll be talking about a specific type
of plasmid which is used to express
proteins in mammalian or in bacterial
cells it is called the expression vector
now expression vector could be used for
several reasons it could be used to
purify a specific protein
I mean first expressing the protein in a
bacteria or in a mammalian cell and
followed by purification then to study
protein localization in a cell also to
make a recombinant protein or enzymes
such as
insulin now also geneticist could use
the expression vector to create dominant
negative perturbations
in the cells so expression vectors has a
wide variety of usage so in this video
we'll be talking about the mechanism of
the mechanism by which protein vector
the expression vector works and how
they're similar to plasmids and what are
the differences between what are the
modifications in this expression vector
compared to plasmids
so like any vector this kind of
expression vector also has antibiotic
resistance which work like a selectable
marker now origin of replication which
would allow the vector to multiply and
also a multiple cloning region are
multiple cloning sites where there would
be several restriction enzymes where you
can I mean the restriction digestion and
allow your gene of interest to be
integrated into that region right but
one interesting thing is in this
particular expression vector you have
you have to get the expression vector
inside a bacteria yeast or mammalian
cell and you expect the protein needs
protein to be expressed inside them
right so you need to have appropriate
promoter such that the RNA polymerase
can bind and transcribe and further it
could be translated so anything related
to transcription and translation machine
should be present in this vector
backbone otherwise the purpose of the
vector won't be fulfilled right so let's
talk about what are the new features or
what are the additional features
compared to a plasmid
so the expression vector has the
inducible promoter by which you can
spatio-temporal control the expression
from the expression of the gene of
interest and also have the gene of
interest definitely then in terminal 10
and this kind of in terminal or C
terminal tab comes very handy when you
want to like purify the protein like
affinity purification so you always have
a GFP tag or hiss tag to purify the
proteins sometimes mannose binding
protein or other tags allow the protein
to be more soluble and thereby easy to
purify now if you have a fluorescent
marker then it would be easy to track
the protein or the localization of the
protein inside a cell right then you
have shine-dalgarno sequence and in a
moment we will talk about why it is
there polyadenylation site and
transcription stop sites all are the
feature of these expression vector but
wait wait wait it's like a information
overload they're like too much
information let's break it down one by
one so first let's talk about an
inducible promoter now we know that in
case of eukaryotic translation the
transcription you need a promoter region
where the RNA polymerase will bind and
start transcription right so you need a
promoter region and without the promoter
region the transcription cannot be
started so most of the cases if you want
to express the protein in bacteria a
good inducible choice would be Lac
operon right the lac promoter could be a
good choice because by default lac
operon is off but inducing we can that
can be induced by the presence of a low
lactose or a synthetic variant of a low
lactose called iptg other systems like
Tate on Tate off system could be also
useful especially for mammalian cells
now if you want more information about
lac operon and Tate on Tate off system
you can visit my molecular biology
playlist and watch the videos on that
then we talk about shine-dalgarno
sequence now let's say our vector is
expressed expressed inside the cell it
has produced their mRNA but the mRNA
which is produced inside the cell it
needs to bind to the ribosome right and
the ribosome binding requires the
shine-dalgarno sequence which interacts
with a specific 16s rRNA sequencing that
I was almost small subunit which allow
the ribosome attachment into the mRNA
so the signed are no sequence should be
also present in that expression vector
itself now two important sites
transcription stop and polyadenylation
site are super important because there
are sequences which allow the
transcription to be out and thereby
falling of the RNA polymerase in a row
dependent or independent manner but all
in case of eukaryotic specially the
polyadenylation is very important and
without the polyadenylation by specific
enzymes like see PSA for CT cstf these
enzymes which trigger polyadenylation
they are very important because without
the polyadenylation the mRNA are
unstable and the environment would be
degraded so the protein won't be
expressed because the mRNA which is
produced from the expression vector it's
degraded in a moment so all these
factors are so important in terms of
expression vector or all these factors
matters when you want to choose the
expression expression vector for your
experiment so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give a
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you